but oh he's how his rook back his rook
in the process he 595 is coming I don't
know who's better here and why I don't
know who's better either Robert freaking
out I think it's a draw I think with
best place to draw because you're
probably best play is a draw
team d5 the knight was almost trapped so
you asked me to go to play king b5 not
sure why your car went for this he's
gonna settle on the draw unless he's got
a win with oh my god what a swindle oh
that was so I almost cursed on chest out
comp TV for the first time in my life
[Music]
Robert yeah I've got my coffee I've got
my sippy cup I've got you next to me is
there anything else I could ever need in
this world well Danny can you handle
this alright producer can you handle
this hey Karan Ali Raisa can you handle
this I don't think I can handle this
Danny I'm so excited for the business
going to be it's gonna be the best half
hour of my weekend right now so I'm the
only thing I'm not ready for it besides
you're jelly is is that is that the rest
of my weekend is going downhill after I
see Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura and
Grandmaster al-idrisi firoozeh Perugia
throw down and what's going to be
perhaps the the the biggest match of the
day I mean I don't want to say that
because we got five hours ahead of us
dude and so many exciting exciting games
ahead of us but it doesn't really seem
to be anything is more anticipated than
what's gonna happen right here obviously
if we talk about the bracket and and
everything that we've been building into
as far as the bullet chess championship
goes you've got the number one seed
Hikaru Nakamura and then you've got
maybe his most formidable opponent
potentially of course I'm excited to see
what happens in every matchup facing off
against him in the first round Robert
yeah there's a phenomenal first round
matchup I know there are a lot of people
being like couldn't this be the finals
well you know it couldn't be but maybe
in the future years it will be it for
years to come at that and Danny we just
have so many great matchups today we've
got a ronia car yeah and I'm
particularly excited about that one
because I'm really not sure how good
those players are at 100 I've seen them
play one one in this championship but
without the increment when the gloves
come off I want to see how they are down
to the wire when they miss just minimal
time on the clock agreed 100% I can't
wait to see what happens I I know what
Hikaru Nakamura is capable of when
there's no increment I know what faroush
is capable of and and right now I know a
little bit more about the right side of
the bracket than they do about the left
because we've been seeing bortnik and
federico perez Ponza who by the way is
he not the Argentinian Eric Rosen with a
little bit of blush on his cheek we
gonna can we get a
image of what Antonio Banderas and Eric
Rosen would look like if they had a baby
well we've got it right in front of us
federico perez poncy that's another
discussion let's get into the discussion
because the games are about to start
Robert we don't need to have any other
hype besides remind everybody of what
the format is we're about to see 30
continuous minutes a clock counting down
just like the sec of bullet chess
between a Cara Nakamura and Ollie Riza
firoozeh the players have been seated
obviously in the most traditional
fashion by rating and pared off and the
games will will go if a game is started
before the timer runs out of course it
counts anybody who's watched the SCC
knows knows exactly what that's about
and of course if the players are tied at
the end of this then we have overtime
that's just more free chess and more
excitement for all of us so that's gonna
be welcomed by everybody I'm ready I'm
ready - welcome - welcome this Robert
I'm so excited here we go Hikaru
Nakamura all the reason firoozeh This Is
It this nervous it's a matchup you know
me I almost never get nervous I am
nervous for this because I know that
hick car was the favorite he definitely
is but firoozeh is a absolute monster
and I really think he could pull this
off I'd probably give a car what deed
what would you give me 80% chance of
winning is that too high am I giving too
much credit I don't think so I think
Hikaru is motivated he's been hearing
the chatter he saw Ali Risa set the new
all-time record and I think a car was
coming here as motivated as ever we just
got some cheers we got a lot of stuff on
screen right now but I'm gonna also
remind everybody that starting tomorrow
we actually have a new format we're
trying for the first time and since we
just asked the daily question before the
games start let's actually tell
everybody what that format is for those
of you who didn't get the memo tomorrow
we're doing something a little different
which is a win counts as a point and you
must get 6 points within a set what
makes that different well one thing is
that if there's a draw it doesn't count
for for anything a lot of people have
talked about how do we keep chess at the
highest level super exciting with the
increased amount of draws well we came
up with an idea that says how about
draws just won't count and if you draw
guess what you might play a hundred
games if you're gonna keep drawing games
try to find a way to win because only a
win counts as a point you must get six
points to
when asset and asset must be won by two
points yes this is this is exactly what
you would see in a in a tennis match
tomorrow's first match which is the
consolation event will be will be a
best-of-three set series to win the
match the championship will be a
best-of-five set the other thing that's
really exciting about this format Robert
is that in theory we don't know how long
a match could go because if somebody
wins the first two sets but then loses
the next two I mean there's always a
chance for a comeback which one of the
things that happens that can be a little
deflating in chess as you know is if you
lose a ton and ton of games now a
20-point deficit is just frankly
insurmountable but in this format the
structure is such that if you lose a set
you're always starting fresh in the next
set and in theory there's always a
chance to come back and win the whole
match so get involved with us use the
hashtag bullet chess on Twitter let us
know if you think this is an interesting
approach to match play settings and
chess Robert your thoughts about what
we're trying to do tomorrow no I'm
excited for that because it's good you
know you said it's really tough when you
feel like you're just lost
early on you God tilt you lose a bunch
of games but in this format when is
tennis scoring you could lose five games
in a row in just about all right
this set is over you take that one but I
have a chance to come back right and
that's really important especially a
bullet when tilt is the norm and you get
a little bit of break between sets you
could calm yourself down okay that one's
over but such like losing you know one
portion of the event rather than the
whole thing and I think it gives players
motivation to continue fighting whereas
you know of course all the players are
trying to win it every game but there's
something deflating about losing much
games in the row right and and our hope
is that that'll that'll keep both the
players and fans engaged as long as
possible I don't think people need more
engagement than what they've got here
hey Cara's hair is blowing in the wind
only Reese's got what looks like a very
very welcoming living room there and I
think I think we're ready to rock
I'm just waiting for the team due to get
the party started I'm with you Robert
I'm strapped in buckled in right pull
the belt tight and low across your hips
remember your seat is not a flotation
device now this show but hopefully there
won't be too many hard crash landings
and I just had to figure out after you
gave that
a great point about Ponza being in
argentine Eric Rosen I'm just rying to
figure out with this tennis score would
he be more a1 martín Del Potro or will
he be a Diego Schwartzman and I'm not
sure it's really giving me a little bit
of a headache right now to think about
that because they're so different but
let's get this underway I'm Danny I'm
not strapped in to my seat
I haven't buckle my seatbelt you know
I've always been the problematic child
so kids going I'm so sleeping I'm
waiting we're ready let's go let's go
this show is starting I think we're
about 30 seconds away and then we're
gonna have 30 minutes of non-stop bullet
action hey Cara Nakamura Ali Riza
firoozeh I'm gonna try to say his name
with different emphasis on different
syllables all day not because of any
disrespect but because I love saying his
name fuchsia fuchsia I just love it I
love it it rolls off the tongue
kind of like his chess moves roll onto
the board when he dominates most of his
opponents in bull of chess but I you
can't get a tougher a tougher opponent
than one hit car Nakamura so just like
that the games are underway and we have
liftoff here we go oh there we are and
we have a car with the white pieces out
to a quick three second lead on the
clock and a better position because look
at that controlling the pawn breaks now
the nice hitting it's a d6 right away or
we take on e5 I'm gonna say the bishop
on b7 was under fire but he took with
the pawn instead of the night yeah he
wants you to make use of that pin there
and now look the F files take on b7 with
with the knight to come before it's free
pawn but she was a target here all your
Issa has his own crusher to bring now
there's a threat of Knight takes b3 or
did it Cora miss it no I think he was
taking on before anyway so there was a
little bit of pawn swapping through
non-traditional means and right now
what's going on he six is a problems
Queen me five played before next check
that night away there it is
and okay oh now he's got a double attack
on the rotor 46 I don't think firuze you
saw that yeah now working 7 check was a
threat so you hit him with a knight but
watch out the c2 and before both under
attack yep look at him go pushing that
bless there's always potential I was
gonna say there's always potential when
a rook and Knight have fresh six a
quarter wings to be six month all my
gosh and we saw the natural reaction
right there yeah he's a oh you know what
bleep yeah that was like that was like a
bleep irmak bleep er son here comes F no
okay you can't play it for you you might
wanna play brooch III oh no ageru just
not starting out well shakes his head
and says alright time to time to refresh
things before that's a bad start that
was not a good start for her car oh
absolutely and the the next game is
already underway and fruit is already
down eight seconds what's going on here
this is a great opening choice buy a car
by the way and he would play this in a
classical game it's one of those slow
hippopotamus type positions where you
don't commute anything too soon we all
know as Danny like to say people just
was afraid of commitment and now he's
committing to the Kings side and he's
wasn't gonna talk about your dating life
but you brought it up so how is no I'm
kidding well he take away the f5 square
which is very important now there's
sacrifice on h3 at the right moment now
you have 6 to h5 that we can go pawn to
f5 to the break there was Bishop takes
h3 there but her car didn't do it yeah
I'm gonna get a second chance but he's
also up 11 seconds in the clocks instead
of playing the best move and I agree
with you Danny this is a missed
opportunity he's playing so quickly in
the clock going just for the tactics I
think he needs to slow down I I know he
car is amazing how can I tell him what
to do in bullet he's so much better than
I am but I think you're right there is
always a bit of a hangover when you lose
the first game you get so amped right
you're trying to both win the game in
front of you and make up for the
previous loss which is always a bad
thing to do right can't play against
your demons of the past okay but that's
that I don't I'm waiting for you to say
day that make up chess is never quite as
good as it sounds make up chess is not
usually worth the fight as much as some
chess players can be addicted to that
cycle but okay we'll talk about
relationships again later wait okay so
what's going on here is obstacle
ambitious business I did not convert
that the best way we thought it but
again look at the time advantage you
highlighted so as much as we criticize
him oh okay g4 that's also good yeah he
even could have played rook h1 check and
swung around to 81 to go for the a pawn
he's gonna do it the second time and all
the reasons gonna run and try to defend
I really don't think that this is
anything but hit Carters game to win now
with so much time on the clock unless he
gets himself mated that would be the one
way this backfires is if this King walks
okay
Brooksie allows for good faith oh my
gosh I have got to calm down
oh my gosh I was like I think you spill
coffee and yourself we're at the Zamboni
honestly yeah that's why I got a sippy
cup you know I got drink some tea right
now because this is just a pleasure to
watch well despite a rough beginning for
her car oh he he blew an extra pawn on
the B file and then he walked right into
a fork but I forgetting game one you win
the next game and we only have 26
minutes left in this first quarterfinal
matchup if you're just joining us
everybody I know you're like hey isn't
this the championship no it's not this
is only the start of the day which
should get you amped because we have one
quarterfinal match after another until
we get to the semi finals and then eight
and then it just gets even more fun and
more intense so this has become this is
like my new favorite event is that just
because of the instant gratification
world we live in where bullet is the
only thing that can get my heart pump
and Robert analyze me I think so I'm
gonna psychoanalyze you right now
rookies hanging I think that's the
problem
Purusha is okay he's all in on it on
until tisha tacky
hikaru can go for a mate I thought he
might play brookie one just to free the
f1 square for the Queen to guard h3 more
aggressive and even better and not
ferocious best start here he shakes his
head so naive 9h for even h4 defends the
g2 square from 8 right and the Queen
can't even go to h3 anyway cuz the
pollen is being spied on h5 okay
interesting tonight's for kept the extra
material but he instead he's up seven
seconds he's up in exchange but the
positions closed Dani how was he gonna
get this one because the e4 pawn is the
only target and now take life's falling
oh I thought d5 would fall but I know
some reason for Russia didn't take it d3
I know he had rook d3 I was just about
to highlight it but he blundered it so
it might be worse here despite being up
the exchange he's worse but he's up
three seconds in the clock but I think
blacks black is better here hey car was
gonna go for the window he's gonna find
a way to move the king of may be
sacrificed he have to pawn I don't see a
way to do that that looks tiny interest
okay well you were right that he settles
on the peaceful result shakes his head a
little bit it feels like that one got
away from him yeah that was definitely a
missed opportunity Dani I mean he had a
great position he was winning on the
board he missed Knight h4 a defensive
move right moving our knight back or any
backwards is always the hardest one to
find especially when you've no time in
the clock here this is great for Hikaru
he is the bridge of a beautiful diagonal
now not not only is it great for Hikaru
objectively here but this is also great
for Hikaru cuz he's able to play his
normal bullet style which is this double
fianchetto kind of Hedgehog setup that
anybody who follows a car who streams or
follows his game know he loves if he can
do this and be in his comfort zone all
day against people Robert this is gonna
be what people thought it would be right
Hikaru was who we thought he was because
I think in order to beat him today
somebody has to beat this system because
it ok objectively Robert this double
feeding cattle setup is kind of dubious
there's a reason the karo doesn't do
this in OTB chess right but if people
can't challenge and beat him in that
opening when it's objectively a dubious
position you really don't have a chance
you know you've got to get him out of
his comfort zone and look at the clock
situation you clean you know he's in his
comfort zone when he's up 10 seconds in
the clock every single game against
Yahoo we've seen be the absent monster
that he is and this is good news for
Nakamura fans and you're right Danny I
think he's out to prove that people
saying oh well didn't you see Ali raise
the past 3300 it caught on his stream
said I mean he didn't hyper bullet chest
30 seconds presiding he beat Eric Hanson
some like 42 3 I don't know if that's
accurate but you know it goes up like
that yeah he's very very slow ho Hikaru
is just working it right now
yeah with no diggity he bagged up the
pond and brought it on the a file this
is a this is a Hikaru special right now
and and like you said he he wasn't I
I don't think he was critical those who
follow her car a stream know that he
he's obviously competitive we and we
love that about him but I don't think he
was critical of Holly Reese's record he
was just saying look hyperbole it is a
different game than traditional Bullitt
and he's absolutely right right and he's
saying look you know I think at some
point we might even consider having a
different rating systems for Hyper in
Bullitt we don't have that now but it is
a discussion being had so um you know I
think he's right I don't think it was
anything bitter but it does mean a
little bit of motivation for her Caro to
prove that he's number one here
not all ariza who owns the all-time
bullet rating record yeah it's funny
right you don't want to poke the bear
and in this case a Caro is tends to be
known as the best look at that tactic we
had a cake see - I don't know that this
is
actually working out well for her car
this one no my car is better he's got
he's yeah I was just gonna say but
blacks kink is open and right as I said
that I've regretted saying this wasn't
good for Hikaru as long as you don't
hang mate on G - yep and he's starting
to scoop up some pause they're gonna be
free his back rank and then yep he plays
h3 and here kook
yep he's gonna take on 87 and say you
know I'll get the Queen as the two
worked up and he's gonna drive the ape
on likey likey like it owes him money
and that's what he's doing here comes a
five as soon as the b-pawn protects it
there goes and d3 checks it was the
position Queen h5 and Queen takes d5 is
what I thought he did but he took first
okay unless the rooks find a perpetual
here everybody these are the types of
positions where the Queen can just
dominate the two towers because the king
is open and you have targets on the
other side of the board to worry about
the the rooks need focus they need
coordination any doubling and and second
and seventh rank control oh but hey Cara
blundered a perpetual for it that is a
mistake Ollie Reese's should have gone
for it he's gonna regret that I think
yeah he kidding okay now he now he has
it one more time I think he'll do it
yeah okay so he won't regret it
oh oh he's making him he's made him if
he gets overlooked to h6
oh give her down hey Cara found the
drummer's maid okay well hand it to the
kid who's hanging with him he may be 15
years old but he's you know he's old in
spirit when it comes to bullet Ches and
look all the only reason shakes his head
he kind of knows he got away with one
there Hikaru Hikaru got a little bit too
frisky for his own good he should he
should still have a lead right now but
hey we are deadlocked at two and half
games apiece the people are getting what
they pay for here on Twitch so they get
nothing oh wait a second anyway purujit
looks so concentrated I've been looking
at this video and he's just like head
down
no no one could tell him you know what
to do he just focus and there's gonna be
some Knight f3 check that's why he wants
came to h1 to avoid any tactics on the
f3 square they might have been missed
actually by both sides that couple moves
ago but here we see that a car with the
black pieces has bad pawn structure oh
look at that 91 yep
jus before oh wait a goodie for wasn't a
hanging stuff with a back ring made
around the back ring was under fire as
far as I know Hikaru is still just much
better this game but um but okay
national master the truth sets while
Hikaru was thrown two wins away if you
take that first game and that second one
I agreed he does seem a little off at
this point but give firuze you some
credit right not many people even create
enough opportunities for her car to go
wrong so but shout out to all the
chatters chess TV twitch TV love you
love you all thanks for being here it's
great news when you could play you're
not best bullet chess and still be tied
to an f2 and a half against the car
knocking words good sign it's gonna come
in the future here and right now there's
some nice e5 ideas and watch out for
long before you want the diagonal those
light squares look at that breaking of
d5 this should be and then okay I
thought I thought you were right to you
but he still has other ways to do and he
can put the fish money at the second
time he still doesn't do it though yeah
that is curious because now yeah you can
see hey Carlos body language he's kind
of creepy yeah he's he's not happy with
how he approached that it now he has to
wonder number eight seven I don't want
to say what I just read hick or his lips
is saying but let's just say it wasn't
explicit 'iv and he was happy with that
fist pump
wow he moved the bishop back and all
there is I forgot that the Queen could I
jumped in she - whoa this is intense
ya know Hikaru Hikaru needed that one he
wanted that one and he got it
shoutout to DJ at G wars that's our boy
the tedster hanging in the chess TV chat
everybody on Twitch yeah Carl hey Carl
wants this match don't you don't you
think anything other than that well
they're playing by the way like this is
again no this is such high quality chess
given given what we're seeing as far as
one oh and look at this in exchange
sacrifice for white just pushing the
queenside pawns with black stone Knight
b3 and fork the rook and the bishop
winning for black but because it's
bullet look at the Queen side b6 b7 I
have the b8 score under my control just
so you couldn't take a five because b4
would a fork oh whoa yeah they take b7
rook c8 so how when the okay he knows oh
my god it's he could have two passers
now I think acara blundered that just
straight up yeah he did but at least you
got the good nice 95 minutes and I came
to c4 and b6 and somehow this isn't easy
for
Arisa yeah what's what's the deal here
broke a fisherman there must be a wind
yeah he Cora was gonna simplify I don't
think that was best but the black king
was coming from EA to d7 anyway so this
is just a matter of O'Leary's of
figuring it out
yeah he got although okay hey Carter
does still have a night there's up no
okay he decides there's too much time
there shakes his head and again we're
back to a tide match with only seventeen
and a half minutes remaining on the
total clock so you know this is um and
so yourself everybody this is gonna be
close it's what we addressed anything
though hey car in that game was up ten
seconds on the clock maybe there was a
moment or two where he could have spent
some of that time yet to find a better
plan for because he had great
compensation with those queenside pawns
and look at this game firuzan going all
forward in the distance what firuzan
needs to do everybody this is a this is
an attack that White has to start to get
against Hikaru's favorite fee and keto
systems the way you the way you beat
this stuff is chess principles which is
you just get a big center and then you
use it and it looks to me like blacks
attack is stronger though oh yeah I
agree
yeah just nicely for ideas coming he
trades the bishops first in the night f2
is a threat so you put it's working won
and now next e4 is coming in near future
watch out nicéphore all that's gonna
hurt if you land a knight their Accardo
does it you guys use under fire so he's
really going after b2 and now can he how
can he do this Knight takes no no he's
gonna watch out if that bishop ever
moves there's a discovered check on this
diagonal he found it though c2 sin we
take C 8 because c2 was hanging with no
matter what okay
I missed that yeah I didn't realize how
forcing that was well why did he take on
c2 the cg one's been hanging oh this
back rank mates he's worried about the
the H pawn getting out of control but
this is the right idea just give back
some of the material you have extra if
you're her car to open up question for
the Brooks hanging yeah and all the
reason is gonna throw in the tail okay
well wow this is it's this is this is
one win after another have we seen
either player win two in a row yet I
guess we did all the reason won the
first game then hit caught no because
there was a draw in the middle I don't
think we've seen a two in a row by
either player yet no we have not but for
a hikaru he you know he's playing very
quickly
playing well I think he's been playing
slightly better than Fuji I don't think
that's an insult to say I think just
that we've seen a car throw away some
results and for firoozeh he's in more of
a beneficiary but yeah that's not taking
their waiting for it he's keeping it in
there on the clock to keep me there on
the board to an extent where he can
still see this game it's a rare sitting
setting to see firuze you're better on
the board and on the clock yep and
slightly better black because what is
this isolated pawn now Bishop c4 was a
better move he had Bishop c4 it taken me
six missed an opportunity or a missed
the chance for a skewer there which
would have changed the structure yeah
that he needed to do that number he's
gonna go for the obsolete bishops and
he'll still be worse only for Russia can
win this endgame yep except for the
clock that's the only way hit car has a
chance here and take on d5 Bishop takes
Bishop to Bishop on at four oh he comes
for the reckoning I guess that's fine
still though this should be a draw by by
X's and O's of chess if that matters
three now he lost the pawn rook to b3
okay one seven there so yeah there's
still rook c7 coming in who's seven all
right hit car was better yeah Oh was
that pawn gonna be stopped
okay it wasn't yeah g6 is a bad move
back when he played it because get a
trade off my Brett I can't even like how
quickly they recognized a car taking
with the rook knowing that black can't
stop the a palm at the king just
incredible yeah and King h4 would have
been met by mate so he didn't press King
up there but the next games already
underway so we can have time to talk
about it but here Persia adopting in
English set up his avenging prappas
Nighy one night see to get to do for
what's a piece
Richard wondered in blunder this is a
very common tactic in this opening you
got to watch out for the the extrusion
shaking his head there the expansion on
the B file is very typical in these
English everybody but you gotta be aware
of the common tactics that occur in the
middle games that you play which is why
Accardo keeps playing these systems
because this is like a car this is like
probably Hikaru has played this position
this is a walk in the park right yes
there's a million times yep and here we
see that encourage some piece and I sent
as many times in the past again it just
because the car is so good then you're
higher rated player classical chess if
they're about level of bullet strength I
think as you play a match format the
higher rate of classical player sort of
rises to the top
and the reason I say is because you just
know you see things a little bit more
quickly
I think most of the top players do that
and hit car especially and I just feel
like his familiarity and you know the
promise age yeah he's a little
frustrated here because he didn't
convert good at you oh my god
commentators curse if there's ever one
oh my gosh and again we have still not
seen either player deliver back-to-back
victories in this match so the storyline
this is where it starts to get close it
feels like a better NBA team who's just
letting the other team hang around if
you get into the fourth quarter and
we're still saying well it seems like a
car was playing better but he doesn't
really have a lead
then maybe anything could happen here I
mean hey Carlo has has been playing
better he's been winning several games
that he has not converted and the kid is
sticking with him Wow I mean I can't
believe that that is just that's just
ridiculous
that was he want a piece he wants out of
the opening it was oh and I would say I
said it was a walk in the park from the
perspective that well he was up a piece
in the opening and why does root beer
make you burp and why is he car was so
much fun Thank You Jerry well play oh
wait well firs you're opening up that
Bishop was that's a bad decision for
sure cuz I'm the bishop was dominating
on the light squares yet beside gonna
have have a say here fruta has to back
that thing up to g5 take a just like
juvie taught him - oh I thought rook b1
would have been better put the rook on
b5 Vacarro okay he's gonna do that the
second time around look for Bishop c6
the Brookes gonna infiltrate the yeah
he's got the right idea now there's like
a lesson on chess comm I saw someone
maybe was it was Goldust Tori doing some
lessons for chess calm yeah I should say
and there's something like this where
you show the rook to b5 taking it Queen
side and there's no checkmate right
Bishop f4 is met by Queen you want Oh
Queens have to at any point all right
even if Queen g3 well this is a good
counter-attack now the real can I face
much better place Queen g3e for ideas
and all the reasons up on the clock so
Hikaru
I'll get this though seamlessly and with
the attack at an obstacle Bishop
position this is danger zone the highway
to it and Hikaru has never been no he
has bent down because he lost the first
game of the match so this would be the
second time for each I had a lead here
we wise bruise not taking enough three
take the pollen of three I don't know
and now he's blowing
yeah I mean but who's good this is maybe
the first truly dead equal pure time
screen but we've had today who's gonna
flag the other there's no way a car
loses this game on time or maybe there
is that kinky four but tg4 doesn't do
anything yeah they agree to withdraw Wow
wow that was pure mouse being there who
only 11 minutes left I want to make sure
that that our team I know you're
listening is letting the players know of
the total time remaining of just so that
they're aware of the match situation
saying that out loud to everybody it's
okay to do that sometimes make sure the
players know how much time is remaining
between games yes essentially so that
they know the situation they're in so
many of you with us roughly 3000 of you
332 active members chatting in the chest
comm TV room whether it would matter
where you are thanks for spending your
weekend with us Purusha who's going
all-in here in this is how you got to do
it he called Oh doing a bit of a head
Bob though feels like he's gonna survive
this despite being under the major
attack but now with that pawn capturing
the night the tact feels yeah way less
potent and now blacks up in exchange
this is Hikaru's game what we said so
many times before
hey car we need to put this one away you
cannot let free to stay around you know
you've been out playing him for most of
this match thus far she's got to put a
good game together from start to finish
and bruiser looks like a good
second-half team you're making a
basketball reference before that's a
first looks like to me how did the gates
he's a little slow he's giving us the
time trouble in trouble on the board and
then when the it matters most
843 just go for that pump gotta go away
for a three there's bits of Comus people
surprised that Hikaru's bullet strategy
has a loud Ferruccio of this h4 h5 h6
idea I don't think it's objectively very
good for for white but in a bullet game
it does create some dysfunction ooh and
now a carro might od5 saying yeah a5 and
b4 falls next that was the ambulance for
Hikari Shiina round he car is up five
seconds on the clock though typically
where he belongs and in bullet matches
up on the clock but but this is this is
close yep oh the bishop here
unfortunately eliminated at the cost of
the D pawn for firoozeh
here comes c5 c4 she's up on the
Unitas the night is super tricky in
these end games just watch out for the
night you can pre move with confidence
with a night very often yes you're very
good at fine premium definitely can be
m4 take hey Carlo maybe lucky for a draw
well not easy for boy here comes the H
pawn though the eight pots faster but we
know these got we dictate one oh my god
I think our was not happy right now he
is down a game in this match with only
eight and a half minutes to go eight and
a half minutes have minutes to go in the
half an hour the quarterfinals the
quarterfinals everybody our thirty
minutes
the semi czar 60 minutes and then
tomorrow we have the brand-new format if
you're just joining us boy are we in for
a wild one today if this is how we're
starting things wow this is insanity
this is insanity and you know Danny I
heard you were a wild one but right now
dakaru he music reign himself in he's
got a tamed himself because he's been
playing such good chess but and being up
on the clock but not putting everything
together the critical moments yep no I
mean it's been it's been a surprise to
see it as close as it even is right now
again Hikaru in a very strong position
Knight takes c6 mate is being threatened
on the board yep and his think ro has
made has made blunders in winning
positions and wall up on the clock and
he just made another one he loses his
Queen and he's got to recover this is
one of those I mean your car was just
completely on the attack the only
aggressor and he just threw away that
game what in the world here we lost the
call and that's okay we're gonna
continue to show right now it's solo Dan
solo adventure welcome everybody I'm
steve-o and let's go hunt some
crocodiles
shout out to the late and great
crocodile honor alright well what do we
have here we lost the call and Hikaru
Hikaru might be on the verge of losing
this match if he doesn't pull it
together we have somebody won two games
in a row for the first time and it was
not the guy you might have expected not
Hikaru Nakamura but okay he has to
recover he's the better player he knows
it and and right now he's got a
he's gonna take a to he's up on the
clock as well as up on the board but you
get in that danger zone with only this
much time left this is very SCC ish
right we're a firoozeh just gets one
more win now you can start milking these
games right he can milk this game out as
long as possible to make sure that it's
that it's um that it's taking time off
the total match clock so remember the
gamesmanship of this format which makes
it super exciting right different than
traditional chess events in that way
getting some messages here of people
trying to trying to rejoin we will have
everybody back in just a moment so don't
you panic baby birds Mama's here here
come's of rookie card US has to make
sure he doesn't blunder anything on the
age file it's not gonna be that easy
okay he does have the rook h5 so maybe
maybe I'm wrong maybe we will have some
lemon squeezy here it is easy for Recaro
he converts it and they play another
game hey Danny my back can you hear me
you are back sir we've got City hey Cara
needed me to leave for him to win that's
what happened hey he's like Robert get
away from right right now here Carla
needs every win he can get dude we are
we are down to only roughly I think five
and a half minutes going 3,000 of you
with us thanks for being here
sit tight through our our small
difficulties here but it's a live show
that's how you know it's not rehearsed
and that makes you get your money's
worth here on Twitch how much time is
left in the match dude I don't know
we'll get the timer's I think it's about
five minutes and it's only a one game
lead for firoozeh though this is like
I'm like I'm just so surprised that this
matches even where it's at yeah no I
mean her car has blown so many good
positions here and I mean this is just
not was a chance right now the chance
he's got to play quickly work a five
they would have hit the b5 pawn Oh
what's he does indeed win a pawn okay
again this is where you got to give the
kid some credit that he's got himself in
this spot where it's just not gonna be
easy for her Carla at all that none
haunt is gonna run here comes Darrel
Queen 63 was missed free pawn he
could've taken that pawn DJ hey Carl is
just he's playing too fast he's playing
too instinctively because maybe in a
rare setting he's actually a little bit
nervous 94 he went before the foreman he
and acardo's gonna level up this match
possibly I'm not gonna call anything
until it's over though what happens if
there's a tie in the match it goes to
overtime oh my gosh anyway until someone
wins I can't handle overtime I really
can't do it oh you can handle this good
you're ready for my jelly imma shake it
for you so he's gonna turn his Queen on
the dark squid okay so yeah this is
firoozeh doing it okay but here comes
the f7 pawn this is how you 30 you'll
overwhelm so you can get the Queen's off
the board but he's also got a time
advantage so playing tickle here from a
match strategy point of view not a bad
one for a car oh yes absolutely not
you're right so he doesn't keep moving
back and forth it's much harder to move
with yes bishop
you can't move yeah you've got the
eighth-ranked y'all got problems and now
no this end Oh takes advantage of the
free move Cerreta he was dead he knew he
was dead so he was dead and he did what
he had to do whoa he's free moving he's
still down on the clock though despite
the pre moves and her car was gonna take
advantage of that okay Hikaru not gonna
be full twice firoozeh goes for one last
stab in the dark give the kid some
credit right golfclap Wow he would even
though he lost different times honestly
that was really smart but Hikaru ties it
up he was out two games in this match
it's out i seven f7f do the next person
who wins probably wins the match we have
only three minutes remaining
roughly just over three minutes I am OH
three minutes oh my gosh and here is
actually closer to two minutes in the
official game timer will try to update
that for you guys but we are literally
down to the wire we probably have two
games left in the match oh my gosh and
seven have seven have and I hope the
player is keeping an eye on the clock
there because this is critical you
cannot go down either one play either
player here 95 34 takes East Asia is on
the grind watch out for who takes c6 was
a threat followed by the for Connie 7
which is why he karo had to run
submission b5 okay but it's 95 oh I
would not see no this is a favorable
situation for firoozeh the night much
better than the bishop and boy if that
h4 pawn falls down then all of a sudden
think the King side pawns are running
very quickly right you're right okay
well despite the knight being better
look at that Bishop you go to b4
Oh g5 you got g5 super nice move but f7
might fall you're right you're right f7
is falling oh look at that move king of
60 kids rookie 633a 31 second shot but
oh he's how his rook back his rook in
the process he 595 is coming I don't
know who's better here and why I don't
know who's better either Robert freaking
out I think it's a draw I think with
best place to draw because probably best
play is a draw
team d5 the knight was almost trapped so
you actually yeah you should have played
King d5 not sure why he Cara went for
this he's gonna settle on the draw
unless he's got a win oh my god what a
swindle oh that was so I almost cursed
our chests out comp TV for the first
time in my life honestly I might have
been winning at that point because the
bishop cut the king off and if the king
could run the h2 like that in winning
winning the whole time did you carve out
the foresight to see that idea I don't
know why gosh so what's the exact time
left we have 45 seconds left in the
match firoozeh has to win this game or
it's over
oh I'm day total time everybody the
technical glitch lost us a little bit
but this is it and both players are
meter wins or it's over both players
missing Knight 65 tactics there with a 9
F for hanging but well forgive them and
there it is gosh the kid has his chance
if he wins this it goes to overtime but
he's losing this he lost the e5 pawn c6
is hanging next night 66 wins material
no but b2 Falls if you go for that 8 the
Brooklyn da is hanging as well yeah true
but here Cara wants more than that he
wants Bob Barker this he's also 17
seconds he wants the whole thing okay
well 17 seconds oh my gosh this is it
Peruggia has to win this game it's
officially over on the clock and it's
officially over on the board as well
look at any car oh gosh no not yet
firoozeh has to win this game it's over
and it's it I think they're gonna end up
playing one more because they see the
time there but we will inform the
players that this last one officially
actually does not count
Hikaru Nakamura wins the first corner
final by a score of 9 and a half to 7
and a half and I just lost five years on
my total lifespan yeah you can breathe
again Danny
we have a you know we we can abort the
game a chat staff you can abort the game
and let the players know it's over nine
f seven and a half but come do we want
to see over there to let you know that
time is up because he's in the worst the
match is over
hey Cara Nakamura barely gets by against
the youngster ali riza firoozeh
hey karo punches his ticket to the
semi-finals and I just punched my ticket
to more therapy gives me stress the PTSD
is real Robert that was so exciting I
have to admit as somebody who predicted
that hákarl would dominate this match
against people's predictions I was
clearly wrong firoozeh regardless of the
fact that a car will beat himself in a
couple games Robert that was a swindle
that heya karo I don't know if the karo
can hear us but he's there there is he
just took over how they raised his
positioning there he took his position
the car can you hear us
yeah I can hear you whoa Wow dude I know
that that probably was not your ideal
ideal out outlined for how you wanted to
win this match but how close was that I
mean just how nervous were I tell us how
that what went down at your eyes just
now in your match with all the Ariza
yeah I mean for starters I wasn't sharp
I mean I think out of the gate I was
winning at least in the first four if
not the first five games there's this
game I lost I was up the piece there was
a game where I allowed to mate with the
Queen again - to Brooks I just wasn't
wasn't very sharp at the start but
towards the end I felt that I kept it
messy and I think I mean I think the key
was that ali reza wasn't able to stop
stop the streak I mean in a 30 minute
match it's very tricky because it's
gonna come down to whoever kept whoever
gets on a bigger thing I mean we're both
so good that somebody's gonna win two or
three in a row and it just happened that
I was the last one to go on the street
well and how much credit do you give
your opponent for for just I in the
games where you were winning and just
keeping it messy and giving you those
opportunities to go wrong is that
something that he does well in bullet
give those give those opportunities for
tricks
yeah I mean I think all the recipe ously
is just about
version of Dania I mean I think like
when I think about bold players have
played against I think of tactical
players like Dania is being the guy who
plays a bunch of stuff that probably is
just terrible objectively put in bullet
it's very good and ali reza can do that
as well as playing very positionally too
so I mean I think he's just a very good
player and it's really unfortunate that
this was only 30 minutes it would have
been a lot more fun if it had been like
you know an hour if it'd have been some
ease with the finals cuz I think that
would have read bidding for this match
well Ollie ollie Riza can you hear us
there I'm not sure he can hear us so
Robert I'll let you ask our next
question yeah try to get him on the line
hikaru honestly how nervous were you
when you went down to games with about
seven eight minutes remaining on the
clock
well I didn't actually know when we
started precisely I mean if we were to
write one I would have actually had like
a better gauge I wasn't sure at what
point we had started um I mean I feel
like if it's two games it's possible to
come back certainly with games only
going to minutes I wouldn't say I was
panicking I just felt that I just was
playing bad chess I mean really I was
getting good positions in most the games
and then my conversion was very bad as I
said at the start with the actual
winning positions and and then at the
end kind of I just I felt like things
would go my way eventually I was sort of
matter of what they go my way in time
for me to to win or not and I wouldn't I
was panicked like I said I got the
positions and I was getting blown away
on the board that I would have been
panicking because then that's that's a
very bad sign when it felt to me at
least like my mistakes for more
self-inflicted than anything I just you
know you have to focus on the next game
and you know to give you a better
example I would say that the panic here
was a lot less than the panic in my
match against Wesley for example I'm
actually gots Wesley when I was down two
games late in three minutes session I
would say it was far more worrying to me
than this was although I could just
because his slower games even more time
to think but now that I would say was
much more worrying and concerning to me
them than today makes sense never makes
sense well I would say that as two
people that were panicked themselves and
it's not even our match I would give you
a lot of credit for keeping your nerves
together there we were looking at the
total time on the clock and
and looking at things taking away and
obviously excited for both of you but
just really nervous so a ton of kudos
for for keeping your keeping your nerves
together there Ali Riza can you can you
hear us
Ali Reese are you there I don't know
that he is and that's okay well
well congratulations sake are you're
moving on into the semi-finals obviously
you don't know who you're gonna play it
but before we let you go and get that
next match underway let me ask you as
you look at two guys that you've played
a lot against and over the board
classical chess at the highest level
Sergey Karjakin and Levon Aronian
but two guys who probably haven't had as
as many games against you online
certainly not in sudden death bullet one
let me who do you who do you think is
the favorite in that match and who do
you think is a slightly more difficult
matchup for you in the next round
I mean Sergei on the walk all right yeah
yeah I mean I did play Sergei in the
bull portion we played in the speed
chess championship two years ago I
believe and it was pretty close now
whether that's because I had the lead
overall and I didn't need to really put
my foot on gas is a different question
but I'm Sergei did play quite well
throughout the bullet so granted that
was one one not one zero which is which
is quite different but I would say I
expect Sergei to be the more difficult
opponent simply because he's played a
lot more online chess in general than
LaVon has um but I mean really I don't
think anything is gonna be tougher than
I mean if I lose in the semi to the
finals it's completely on me for choking
because I would say Ali Reza's by far in
a way better than than any of the other
players in the field good question
Picaro now that you said that yeah you
make of this bortnik ol exam because he
was very impressive in the qualifiers
and I don't know if maybe you have you
played him before in bullet chess here I
mean I played board Nick allowing a lot
of blitz games and bullet not so much I
mean I knew it well first of all which
one is X there - which one Aleksandr
it's yeah okay they're two of them um I
don't think I've played him at bullet
but again I mean I feel like when you
look at the bullet tears I would say
there are a couple people like myself my
golly Reza
maybe Magnuson maybe Daniel anyway you
got all ear as a soul that you asked him
some questions
hey there Olly Reza you can hear us
oh we can hear him for some reason he
can't hear us
there you go there you go oh oh hello I
first of all congratulations on a on a
very very well-played match you you had
us on the edge of our seats and were you
aware that when you had your first
one-point lead
having gotten two games in a row that
there was only roughly six and a half
minutes remaining in the total match
clock time this was a problem I didn't
know my son it should over 7:30
[Music]
well you you um you played very well and
we're sorry for the confusion there but
either way you guys you know you had a
very close match NSA karo said I think
before you could hear him it was kind of
felt like just a matter of whichever of
you got on a run first in a very short
thirty minute match was probably gonna
win and and and he managed to get those
last two or three but what are your
thoughts on on how the match went today
maybe maybe some in some hindsight some
things you would have done differently
or better to hold on to the minute I
don't know this was the main problem I
think actually before the game bit I got
but of course he's playing favorites and
I think he's stronger than me in this
one how difficult is it to play against
a carros opening system that he plays a
lot in Bullitt how difficult is that
opening system to face he was playing
faster than usual it was not easy for me
to handle everything opening he's
playing some systems that he knows very
well so it's not yeah there is a you
know you did an amazing job hanging in
there early in the match because some of
your positions were very difficult and
you were down in the clock so can you
tell everybody how do you find the
strength in the you know did the defense
to hold on in positions that look losing
on the board and are tough on the clock
as well I think it's about just playing
consistent and I think well we know it's
it's difficult and sometimes there's not
much to say after playing a guy like a
carbon bullet but all the rest you're
clearly a rising star it's a pleasure
for us to be able to watch you go go
toe-to-toe with with a guy like a car oh
and before we let you go I wanted to
just wish you the best of luck in the
speed chess championship coming up where
I think many people see you as as one of
the favorites for sure
and I actually believe I'm being told by
our producer that we're actually gonna
be getting set to start our next
quarterfinal match here so very soon I
think we're gonna bring up on the
bracket and thank both you hick haru and
ali reza obviously Hikaru we will see
you in about two and a half hours I
guess for the semi finals and all the
rezident we're gonna let you enjoy your
night there and again thank you both for
playing congratulations to you both and
Hikaru we will see you soon see you
thank you
and all right so we've we now have a
winner there as
you just saw Hikaru Nakamura beats Ali
Riza firoozeh by a score of 9 1/2 7 1/2
just an amazing match apologies there if
there seemed to be some disconnect and
some of the moments of the interview to
everybody watching but thank you for
sticking with us 4000 of you on the edge
of your seat and these next matches will
probably be just as close i Robert it's
that was that was literally I feel like
all we could have asked for as far as
entertainment and both these guys giving
us a great interview very humble
response is a very complimentary of of
each other they are and just I can't
wait for our next match yeah I can't
wait either Danny I think one thing that
stood out to me in those interviews was
both seemed to be an agreement that foo
just he's not quite there yet
he's an amazing talent he's 15 years old
but he himself said well hey car would
just play better and faster than I did
and that seems to be the general trend
so what's I think that with in time as
Ali Riza continues improve as a chess
player in terms his classical chess
skills he was like he prepared for the
match it goes to show that how seriously
he took it but there are certain
critical moments where her car was out
playing him and yes you know how there
is a did amazing job in the first half
of the match and even up until probably
20 22 minutes in the match he had that
lead of even two games but as the clock
wound down Hikaru found his footing and
he was able to a amazing chess and
played quickly and I saw someone in the
chat saying it might be an unpopular
opinion but Hikaru got a bit lucky no I
I think it car actually got unlucky
throughout the match and this could have
been a wider spread but congrats to both
players yeah very very well all he
raised it was a formidable opponent and
yeah this could have been a Finals
matchup and it will be a Finals matchup
in years to come I believe I couldn't
couldn't agree more with with every word
that's flying out of your mouth the the
I do also agree that Hikaru kind of
almost dug himself a hole that that
almost he almost didn't get out of right
way and it was interesting to hear he
said that he never panicked he if he had
felt like he was getting outplayed that
would have been a different thing and I
agree with you and this you know
sometimes being accused of hikaru
favoritism on chest I just don't think
that's true at all I think he's just
clearly the best player in this in this
situation and and you know we we we call
it like we see it
terms of the advantage on the board was
consistent for her car but his
conversion was not and I give a ton of
credit to Perugia for for like you said
staying in those games keeping it tricky
enough right your your opponents can't
blunder unless you give them the
opportunity to do so right I mean Magnus
Carlsen is very well known for for
creating opportunities for his opponents
to go wrong in classical chess and I
think that there's something to that and
firoozeh not taking anything away for
him to say that as you said he's just
not quite there yet right but who knows
maybe maybe within a year or two this
will be a matchup that um that is a that
is really really a coin flip so and it
almost was today shout out to our last
twitch prime sub there and and everybody
that is throwing your support our way we
just can't can't thank you enough for
being here for watching we've actually
got our our first quick break of the day
we're gonna take right now but when we
come back our next quarterfinal match
will be beginning will be but we'll be
starting so don't go anywhere we're
gonna be right back